Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhassa
homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
So,
trying to make a distinction or trying to talk about the two types of meditation that we find in all forms of Buddhism Samatha and Vipassana Samatha means peacefulness, quietening Vipassana means insight and I think to get an angle of it it's always good to go back to the Buddha's own personal experience and how it comes across to us through the scriptures
So here we have a young man, he's in his mid-twenties, and he's slowly becoming disillusioned with life.
He's living the good life, he belongs to a ruling family, although in later commentaries he's put up to this huge eastern potentate, he's just a local boss.
a local head of a tribe who actually has to pay tribute to the king of Kosala.
So he's what you might call upper middle class, how about that?
And he has a wife and an ordinary family life, extended family life, lots of cousins, many of whom of course join him when he starts the order.
and of course the women join him eventually, and just about the time his son is born.
From a sort of psycho-dynamic point of view, from our Western psychology viewpoint, it's rather interesting that his own mother died when he was only a week old.
And that must have had some psychological effects on him, even though it was his mother's sister who became his stepmother.
And somehow he leaves just as his child is born.
That's a rather interesting coincidence of facts, I'm sure.
Freudians or Jungians might say something about that.
I don't know.
But
one perhaps could say that this trauma even in that young age the loss of your mother does create I think some imbalance in the psyche which begins to manifest in him in his early twenties as what we would call an existential crisis leading to probably an identity crisis who knows and what brings it about is the
realization a sort of sudden growing realization that you know once youth has passed once you've come out of the out of the fantasy of youth where things like sickness old age and death are very far away one isn't concerned with these things anyway concerned with good living
but around about 25 that is a change of view that something happens within us most of us anyway where we realize that in fact you know youth is passing as we know it and we're looking ahead to a glorious hopeful middle age we start taking things seriously we tend to take our pensions get married take a career anyway
from the easiness of youth so within that sort of context he comes to realize that actually in the end there's just sickness, old age and death and it's a sort of crisis which builds up in him to such a degree that it makes him go, it makes him leave
But there's another side to it, which also reinforces that search, is that he's experienced, shall we say, what Blake would call the road of excess, I think that's how he puts it, the road of excess leads to the palace of wisdom.
at some point when he's had all his parties and he's had a good time he sees the vanity of it he sees the other side of it the emptiness of it it's expressed in a visual sense that he wakes up at the end of a big carousing and just sees these dishevelled bodies and maybe the smell of sickness and who knows what and that sort of
gives him the other side of pleasure, you see, the downside of pleasure.
Psychologically, remember, this indulgence brings about the frustration when you can't get what you want, the grief when you lose what you've got, and the anxiety when you've got what you've got and you're afraid to lose it.
So all that psychology is in there, you see.
And we can say that he was waking up to that fact that
The life he was leading had this deeper emptiness to it.
One could say that he hadn't found any real purpose in the family life that he was leading, in the sort of career that was being offered to him as a kshatriya, a warrior caste, a ruler.
And so there comes this crisis point.
We know about crisis, we know about financial crisis.
He's having a psychological crisis.
And so he leaves.
Now he wouldn't have left if he didn't have somewhere to go.
and the thing was that just as in the seventies there was a great movement of hippies searching for love in those days there was quite a movement of people searching for the answer to life in the Hindu, what we call Hinduism, the Vedas there was this slow growing new literature, the Upanishads
which sort of manifests this questioning of the age it was also an age of a change in the culture movement away from pastoral societies dotted here and there with local rulers and things like that to a city based civilization in which there grew a merchant class which had not been there before a rich merchant class that began to have power and kingship which the Buddha didn't particularly like
He preferred the more democratic meetings of the pastoral societies.
So there's ferment, you know, there's change happening in society, not perhaps as vicious as we've experienced, but definitely some dislocation going on.
and there were these groups of men very rare for women to do it because of the dangers involved and of course the sexism involved too who went out into the forests and tried to find the meaning of life that was their job and one of the strains of understanding which empowered them was the
the belief in rebirth, the belief in reincarnation.
And there were many sort of answers to it, but it was the horror of having to be reborn again into this life.
Remember, these times are a bit harder, you know, like there's no videos, there's no DVDs, there's no cars.
I mean, it's, you know, it's sort of dog work, you know, like you're out in the field digging and you come back, what do you do, you know?
Well, we're going to go tonight, you know.
The only entertainments, you might say, were the occasional, the big entertainments, the occasional military parades.
And believe it or not, the holy men who would turn up in their parks, in their shrines, and everybody would go out on a full moon night and ask questions and they'd do some chanting and stuff like that.
That was...
In a sense, the fullness of their entertainment, I suppose, apart from the usual things, playing games.
And the idea that one had to be reborn again and again and again and go through this horror, because in those days, of course, sickness, old age and death wasn't something that happened in hospitals or was shut away somewhere.
The dead were taken to charnel ground.
You could see the bodies rotting.
When the wind changed, you knew where it was coming from.
Like it was there, it was in the open, as you might still see in India.
You see, when you go there, that's one of the great things about India, it doesn't disguise these things.
So this whole idea of having to come back to this, again.
So one was looking for an escape, see, where was the escape?
And that was the atmosphere which the Buddha left home, you know.
And I dare say that when he left, he didn't say, I'm off for good.
So I said, well, I'm just nipping off for a little while and checking this thing out, see if I can find an answer to my deep sense of, my deep disturbance, you know.
I remember when I told my mother that I was going to become a monk, you see.
She collapsed into this such a deep weeping, came from the sort of deepest part of her heart.
Even I started crying.
So I gave her a hug and said, Mum, it's only for three years.
And she stopped like that.
And of course, you have to put it in the context of Catholicism because priests are around.
You can see a priest there.
But if you become a monk, that's it.
You cut your tie.
You enter the monastery.
And nobody ever sees you again.
I think they've softened up on that now.
I think they can see people once a month or something.
But in the old days, that was it.
Left.
Collapsed, you see.
So I dare say there was a lot of...
gnashing of teeth his parents wept in later tales they say how his parents wept at his leaving his wife wept everybody wept and I'm sure he said well I'm only going I'll be back in a bit he's going to see what it's like so he goes off and joins these ascetics living in the forest
And the people he goes to, the first two teachers, teach him what we now call the jhana, what we now call absorption meditations.
And when you practice this Samatha type of meditation, you're creating a state of mind.
But the beauty of it is that although you begin
with an outside object, either a candle flame, you all know that, or a circle, or an inner object like a mantra, or an inner object like your breath, it's still an object.
You're only using it to bring about a certain laser quality to the mind.
and I think you'll know that when the mind begins to concentrate bliss arises naturally it's just the quality of the mind as it concentrates sort of an energy in it and we experience it as a certain type of inner happiness and the first teacher really took him right through what we now recognize as the
the jhanas, the rupa jhanas and the arupa jhanas and now the rupa jhanas are those states that you get by deepening your concentration until as it were the mental state leaves the body goes inward as it were and finds its own joy and then even leaves that to find a perfect peace
This is not the equanimity of the seven factors of enlightenment.
They use the same word, you see.
These words are used variously.
The same word, but they have slightly different meanings.
And then, leaving that, as it were, one enters into a stranger place where there's no object at all.
So, right up until that point, there's always an object, a light, the feeling, a sense, there's something there.
But when that disappears,
And this consciousness, as it were, if I want a better word, flips into a different state and there's nothing there.
And those places are called infinite space, infinite consciousness, infinite nothingness.
These relate, I'm talking now to people just a little bit who know the Dharma a bit deeper.
These relate to the four khandhas, you see.
So when you're into that area of space of nothingness, it's out of that nothingness that the sankhara arises, the manifestations of mind arise.
When you're into that space of consciousness you're at the beginning of the jñāna process of consciousness which manifests eventually as one of the aggregates.
When you're in the space
Everywhere there's just space.
You're at the subtle level of Vedana feeling.
And when you're at neither perception nor not perception, that's the beginning level of perception as that consciousness descends into the mind and finally coagulates into what we call physical body.
So that process that a person might go through, it has its own insightfulness as you pass through it.
And the Buddha took this with his teacher and became an adept and the teacher said, please join me.
And he said, no, he said, although I've done all this and they're very blissful states and all that, but it's not really answered my question as to is there an end to suffering.
Now that's the core thing which I should have mentioned earlier.
The quest was, is there an end to suffering?
And that eventually puts his whole teaching just in three words in the texts, dukkha, dukkha nirod, suffering and the end of suffering.
This dukkha, of course, has a very wide meaning.
Here I've translated it as suffering, dissatisfaction, sense of lack, meaninglessness.
It's the whole gamut of human suffering, from the smallest little disturbance to the deepest despair and horror.
so he leaves that teacher and he finds another one who takes him just one step further than these Arupa Jhanas and there becomes an adept and again he's asked to teach but he says no, he leaves you see so although he's practiced these concentration meditations although he's taken them to the fullest development
recognized by his own teachers, there's just something lacking.
There's something which has not been undermined, which is still causing him suffering, causing him some feeling of dissatisfaction.
So now he tries...
a different tack, which seemingly he gets from an elder teacher, a contemporary teacher, the Nagantha, the leader of the Jains.
Now his understanding was that bad karma was accrued even when he didn't mean it.
So you know that Jain monks go around with a whisk.
and make sure that there's no bugs that they're going to tread on, accidentally, see.
So their understanding is that even accidentally, you still cause suffering, and therefore there's going to be a karmic comeback, you see.
And the real problem lay, and this runs right the way through, really, Indian literature, in desire, trishna, you know.
so one had to live the absolute ascetic life deny the body any pleasure because there was a danger he did not make, he didn't seemingly make a distinction between pleasurable sensations and the attachment or desire that you have to them so one had to as it were undermine that whole process and if you think about it
no pleasures come through the body don't they so you begin to read you begin to blame the body for your problems and you fast you know you you sit in front of very hot fires you do all sorts of ascetic practices which are meant to steal you against the pleasure of the body you see
so he took this again he seemingly took it to his own personal end like he couldn't go any further with it and basically he just got thin and he said he could hold his spine through his stomach that's how thin he was and he hadn't and again he sort of wasn't achieving anything like it is the question is not this fundamental question about
suffering about meaningfulness, had not been answered.
And he's with five companions, remember, at this time.
They're going for it, helter-skelter, and they're really whipping themselves and getting into it big time.
And so he leaves.
So now, in the opening stanzas of his very first talk,
he says that the life devoted to sensual pleasure is base, ignoble, waste of time, leading nowhere and the life devoted to self-mortification which is not renunciation renunciation is not doing something to see your attachment self-mortification is based on self-punishment self-negation in that sort of bad way rejection of life as it is in a way
And that self-mortification was also just painful, he said, and led nowhere.
At least the first one was pleasant and led nowhere, but this was just painful and led nowhere.
But he doesn't say that the jhanas, that the other stuff that he learnt about developing the qualities of mind, was a waste of time.
And that becomes part of his system.
But we can, at least I can,
get a sense of his despair when he leaves his companions and what's he going to do?
he can't go home because it would just go back into that emptiness that bad emptiness he's been to all these teachers he's talked to a lot of people and you can see from his teaching that he knows all the local philosophies of the time and the psychologies of the time they learned that
and he's tried everything and he's got nowhere to go so I imagine that when he sat on that road along which Sujata came he was in a state of real existential despair and thin and when Sujata comes along with her rice pudding or well rice cakes
She takes pity on this man.
I mean, you know, in the scriptures they soup it up.
She's going to offer this to a god and sees the Bodhisattva who is resplendent and believes that this is the god.
But actually, he must be looking miserable.
She thought, well, maybe he needs it more than this god.
And we all know the salvific effect of rice pudding.
It's enormous in its power.
so having tasted it he sort of feels better and around about that time he has this memory of his father doing applying ceremony he's a child and there's something about the way he remembers there's something about the way he's looking at his father doing the applying ceremony
which offers him another way of seeking the end, seeking the answer to his predicament.
And that's why I've got these pictures, you see.
The little baby at the back there on the board was on a poster, was on an advert in Birmingham Station.
And I came out of the train, I saw this.
It was part of an advert.
and I went home and came all the way back to Birmingham station to take that picture.
I'd probably broken some sort of publication rights but I thought it was a fantastic book.
Make sure you have a look at that because what it expresses is that way of looking and the moment of seeing.
And the little girl in the other picture was given to me by
a friend in Dublin, Dennis.
And this is a picture that brought into the Dublin time, the Irish time.
And there was an opening of this, what do you call it, where they put trees and little animals, nature, nature was there, it's not like that.
And you can see that she's reaching out to a plant to see what there is there, but the look on her face, if you look at it, has both an intense interest, but also a sense of trepidation, a sense of fear of the unknown, like if I see this, what will happen?
So that comes first, and the baby face comes second.
Yeah.
So here's this child watching his father doing a praying ceremony and there is a tremendous interest in what his father is doing.
And that interest draws him into an absorbed state.
He's just looking.
And you see it in children, don't you?
You see it when their jaw drops and their eyes become fixated.
And you can't shake them out of it unless you give them a clip on the back of the head.
and that's it, that's the pure openness of that intuitive intelligence just receiving so that's why I try to stress this quiet abiding because there you drop your preconceptions you drop your ideas, you drop your concepts, you drop your history dropping your history and you lay yourself open just observing, feeling, experiencing what's happening right now
so there was something in that looking which raised again that encouraged him to have another go and he was so certain that this would actually be the answer that he makes a determination doesn't need to sit under the tree and either die or find you know find the answer to his to this existential problem of suffering
looking for him looking for us he does six hours it seems there's an interesting moment which is worth pondering the great doubt arises I'm sure you've seen that posture of the Buddha where he's putting his hand touching the earth to ground himself and Mara the evil one attacks him
and although it's put in pictures of all sorts of things attacking him what it is is the great doubt it's known as the moment of great doubt and the doubt is who are you?
who are you to try and work this out?
there's no single human being you know of nobody's ever worked out who are you?
how come you've even started on this quest?
and with it there comes this
the temptation of going back into the ordinary life and that's what Mara is later on in Buddhism Mara is put across as sort of an evil bit like the Christian devil trying to kill you and do all sorts of bad things to you but he's much more the tempter and the god Mara is actually the chief of a most delightful heaven so what he symbolises is the attraction of the sensual life
and it's interesting that when he touches the earth and the earth goddess appears it's his perfection of generosity which makes him continue to sit now what is generosity?
generosity is doing or doing something for somebody else and I presume that what came to him at that moment was that this wasn't just for him
this was for humanity there wasn't a selfish thing that he wanted to get out of suffering he was trying to save himself it was in the greater context that this was the question and it was for the benefit of others that I think gave him that strength to sit there and continue that investigation
I think this is my own interpretation, by the way.
The commentaries just say, you know, it was the quality, the perfection of generosity that gave him the strength.
So when he began to teach...
he taught these two things in tandem and the absorption states were something that he really pushed the thing about the mind is that if it's very concentrated, very open, very still, obviously it sees something
obviously it's more capable of seeing something, rather than a mind that's scattered, unable to be gathered onto a single point.
And one can develop that sort of single-pointed mind through various exercises, and you can do it, as it were, just by repetition, just by repetition.
but remember that when you do that there's a tendency to be able to block to stop the purification process and that's what
the Buddha found now when he was in these beautiful states fine but when he came out again he was still the same old depressed gotama see it hadn't done anything to purify the heart it had built another mindset which as an adept he could enter any time so therefore you could always go to this place when he felt a bit depressed push it away do your mantra in you go blissed out
but it never actually dealt with this problem that's what he came back to and it can't do because these Jānic states are about developing the mind now we see this and this is the distinction between a charismatic who is not wise and somebody who is wise and somebody who is charismatic and wise
somebody who's charismatic builds up this huge love you see and it can become a radiance you can be attracted to it and then one day you stand on their foot and they go berserk so that's why the Buddha says you can't tell how wise somebody is until you live with them for quite some time
and then you suddenly see these little defilements these little odd bits of behavior come out and you know that something has not been purified but that doesn't mean to say that in that charismatic form the person might not be doing a huge amount of good but even that person may be confusing their charisma with wisdom and the great enemy the Buddha points out
of the leader are the followers because they keep telling you how wonderful you are the person who is fully liberated might not be charismatic at all might be quite an ordinary person
even though the Buddha definitely had some charisma there's a lovely moment in the scriptures where somebody a monk comes in or it might have been a lay person I can't remember and comes into a group of monks and has to ask you know which one is the the Bhagavan so it's not as though he displayed this huge charisma or it doesn't seem to have done but then again you can have somebody who is charismatic and who is fully liberated
Now what the jhana does, all these jhanas, is to produce charisma, depending on what you practice.
So if you practice love, that's the charisma you'll get.
In my travels in Thailand, I met about three or four, five people really, five monks, because you only get to see monks as a monk, you know, who were all highly developed, and all of them were generally considered to be liberated.
And they all had very different atmospheres around them.
The two I remember most is an Ajahn Sim who lived just up beyond Chiang Mai.
And there were three of us, we were traveling together, a couple of Americans.
And when you sat in his presence, you were immediately drawn into his sense of peace.
It was a tangible feeling.
And it immediately affected you.
And you sat in peace.
Just like that.
When I went to Ajahn Tate, who had this beautiful monastery up on the borders of Laos, on the Mekong.
I went to see him.
It was just me at the time, I think.
You were just enveloped with this very, very...
lovely loving-kindness.
He might just have been feeling that at the time, I don't know, you know.
But it was tangible.
It was a real tangible feeling.
And immediately softening, you know.
Immediately you felt this open friendship.
When he died, something like, I don't know, what they said, a couple of million people turned up to the funeral.
He was pretty famous.
Ajante.
He's the one I quote, by the way.
I've not, I've said something else out there, but when I do a day of resolution on the retreats, you see, make it simple, take it easy, stay with the one who knows.
That's Ajante.
Make it simple.
Take it easy.
Stay with the wanting.
Now, when the people began to join him, as all the members, Bhikkhus and Bhikkhunis, they were people who'd left the worldly life.
So therefore, what were you going to do?
What do you do all day?
Well, you haven't got to go to work.
What do you do?
And you can't grow anything.
See?
You're not allowed to grow.
You can't cook.
You don't have any money.
You can't buy anything.
You can't do any... You can't get into retail therapy.
And what are you going to do?
See?
You've got to do something.
So these exercises, Jainic exercises, are specifically for those people who have time.
And if you find yourself, you have time.
And this is something you might want to practice.
And...
it's beneficial, it's creating beautiful states of mind.
But, he was travelling once, this is later on in his teaching, out towards Kamasadam, amongst the Kurus, it was a village of the Kurus, and the Kurus lived what we would now recognise as modern Delhi, that sort of area.
He'd been there before.
This is ordinary village people, you know, people who look after cows and sheep.
And the fields, they just, you know, like there's nothing technological.
This is drawing water from the well, cutting wood, all that sort of stuff.
And he'd been there before and he'd given them their teachings.
He'd given them the teachings.
And when he turns up again, he's...
is quite taken by how they're actually practicing the Dhamma.
He says for a start there's no well talk, gossip around the well.
and everybody was doing things mindfully and they were all practicing meditation and he was so moved by this that he gave this talk which is known as the Discourse on the Establishment or Foundation of Mindfulness which is recognized as the jewel of the whole collection because here he actually tells you how to become liberated this is it, he puts it all together in one discourse
and he says it to these ordinary people in Kamathadamma he doesn't give this talk to his monks or anybody now this for me is highly significant because normally speaking he's going on about the jhana and vipassana you know like the one leads to the other etc etc and there are teachers who teach that now yeah
But this, you see, is directed to lay people who haven't got the time to sit there and get into these blissful states.
They've got a tent of family and all this sort of stuff.
And it starts off by telling them clearly
and the word he uses is ekāyāna-vagga which means the one-way proceeding path or the path that proceeds in this single way and the commentary normally puts that as opposed to the dvayāna, the two-way path which is the combination of the Samatha practice with Vipassana
Right?
That's his first words, Ekkayana Magga.
And it's translated variously by authors, depending on their particular viewpoint.
So, you'll see in Jnana Ponika, in his really still, the core book on meditation, the heart of Buddhist meditation, he says it's the only path.
That's a bit fundamentalist.
Then there's these people who are friends down in Devon who translate Pali as a sort of hobby.
And they call it the shore path.
But Bhikkhu Bodhi, who is the doyen, the American monk who's the doyen of Buddhist studies, makes it quite clear that this Ekayana means the one-way path as opposed to the two-way path, which to me makes a lot of sense.
so this is the one-way path for the purification of beings for the overcoming of sorrow and lamentation for reaching the end of suffering and discontent for finding the true way for the realization of emancipation namely the four applications of mindfulness so when we practice vipassana
there has to be included in it a certain concentration content and what the Buddha does is he pulls out for us seven factors which developed lead to this natural insight process and the first one is just this awareness
but it's right awareness and right awareness always means the observation of the three characteristics because that's where the delusion lies it's seeing the impermanence, it's seeing how we indulge or resist what is happening whether pleasant or unpleasant
and the quality of not-self this not-self is not a philosophical statement the Buddha doesn't say there is no self it's a teaching tool in which everything you experience you make clear to yourself is an object you're aware of so if you're aware of something it cannot be that which is aware
if you think of how as children we have begun to distinguish out of that mass of sensation the world out there you know object relationship I think they call it how out of this mass of sensations you know mother starts to loom your first object something separate from you separates out of the mass
until eventually you're quite clear that this is me and everything else is not me all we're doing is taking that process inward and making the inner part of our experience as objective as this room is so this room has a body, walls, ceilings and it has atmosphere, it's a mind so it is the same within us
as we begin to push out, push away, objectify the inner world as we've done the outer world that process is the process of detaching from it undermining that relationship of it being me or mine and that's why we feel this process of liberation that's why the Buddha says the taste of Nibbāna is freedom
it's the liberation from that wrong connection with what we're experiencing but this awareness has to be supported and the split is between those qualities which are passive and those qualities which are active
So when we practice this quiet abiding, we are practicing those qualities which are passive, which for us are not highly developed in our society.
It's the active qualities which are developed.
And those passive qualities are calmness.
Just be calm, not to be excited all the time.
Not to seek a sort of...
high level of energy but to just bring ourselves to a real deep calm and interestingly that's linked with this interest because interest can get excited if you're interested in something you can feel yourself getting all excited but that excitement then becomes that interest then becomes tainted with trying to achieve something trying to see something
once there's a trying to see something that self is taking over the process so to do to see something at this level one has to let go of the idea that I'm achieving it there has to be this business of just having faith a real confidence that there is within us that which will make insight without us trying
and that's the abstraction that's the taking away of this self which manifests as a sort of over effort a trying to see something you won't relax and just let the eye look so tomorrow when you're wandering around tomorrow when you're wandering around the paddock or the garden or you go for a walk just rest your eye on something and just watch the way the eye perceives you don't have to try and perceive
put a leaf in your hand, you know, or just look at a tree and just watch how the eye itself is perceiving.
Stand back from that process and then you gain confidence.
Oh, the eye perceives.
I'll have to try and perceive.
So it's the same with intelligence.
If we get out of the way, the intelligence works naturally because that's the quality of intelligence.
It understands.
It perceives.
It has insight.
It doesn't think.
This is the thing.
Thought is another process.
The insight is immediate.
You either see it or you don't see it.
Then there is this passive quality of a steadiness of attention.
just the steadiness of attention concentration, focus just steadiness, just keeping the attention steady and that has to be coupled again with right effort the effort is just to maintain the focus you put too much effort and you start getting restless you start getting a shaking putting too much effort into it
Too little effort and the concentrated mind very quickly falls into sweet oblivion.
Sleep.
Because that's what happens when the mind's nicely concentrated.
It's calm.
And off you go.
the passive quality of equanimity that's so difficult for us in this sense it's coming from a position of don't know which means that you're looking at something investigating something without any preconceived ideas preconceived notions
that this has to be this way very difficult because on one side we're being fed these three characteristics and then we're told just look forget about that just look and see for yourself and there's no prejudice in the sense that the heart isn't involved in any over desire it's a calm heart you see
All these factors we've talked about are natural to daily life.
Everybody has these.
What turns them into factors that lead to liberation is the investigation of the dharma.
So these same factors would be, so we say, anybody involved in science or some active research.
They're all the same sort of qualities that you need.
Okay?
But once you turn all that to investigating the Dharma, which here it is, these three characteristics, then this leads to a change in the way that we relate to the world we live in.
All that is within this discourse, you see.
This is what he taught lay people.
Right?
And just as a little aside about the Mahasi, whose picture you see here, after the Second World War, when Burma gained independence from us, oh pity, they, who knew the elected prime minister, the only one unfortunately, because in 1963 there was the military coup, which they're still suffering from,
and a group of people were looking for a meditation teacher and the Mahasi was a sort of well-known teacher up in middle Burma and they brought him down and set him up in a meditation center and by all tales a virtual immediate success he had he had he was teaching this he wasn't teaching jhana absorption for which you need time
he was teaching a direct path, it's Ekkayano and he sort of created the parameters whereby people could move quickly so it was great effort as you know it's sitting, walking, sitting, walking 18 hours a day but it was never to try and attain something he was always trying to relax and to watch and to see, to explore
So his effect on the local society in Rangoon was immediate.
Eventually, it expanded so much that by 1956, which is not many years after, he's doing his first world tour around the East.
He didn't come West, I don't think, for a while.
So that's the specific place that the Mahasi holds in the Vipassana scene, you might say, that he teaches this Ekkaya Anamaka, this direct power.
So there we have it, what makes him an especially great person in the spiritual history wasn't just simply the amazing insight that he had, but also his amazing ability to get it across, the Buddha.
to actually produce a systematic way and a systematic teaching which people can understand.
And not just the intellectuals, that's the point, ordinary people, people of Kuru Siddhāma.
So I can only hope my words have been of some assistance.
May you be liberated
of all your suffering, sooner rather than later.